to be a futurist you have to declare
yourself to be a futurist within some
community of futuristic practice right
it's not a thing you can do all by
yourself so for instance to be a
science-fiction brand a futurist I have
to publish some science fiction if I
just write my weird musings about the
future in my private diary nobody's ever
gonna know it's gonna make zero
difference I have to participate in some
kind of publishing system I have to be
involved in the literary world in some
way and I have to communicate otherwise
I'm the Crusoe guy telling himself bar
stories alone
so for me to write a novel about the
future though somebody has to invent the
literary concept of writing a novel with
a setting which is in the future and
that did not happen until the 1600s I
mean people were writing stories for
millennia before anybody thought why
don't I just set it in the time to come
somebody had to and you know undertake
this literary invention it had never
occurred to anybody it was a kind of
Kopernik and breakthrough it was like
wait I could set it in the past or I
could set it at the day or I could like
said it in the future and like this
happened like 10 or 12 times by
different authors before anybody really
caught on and thought you know this
could work it was like independently
invented by a large variety of kind of
Robinson Crusoe style or science fiction
writers who just did broke these
eccentric things and nobody picked it up
nobody went anywhere with it there was
no futuristic community of practice they
would just write it and have it go on so
it was impossible at that time to be
futuristic in the science fictional way
you just couldn't do it until people had
a discourse of scientific romance right
a way to talk about it and they had a
publishing structure and a distribution
structure and an audience and some
literary cliques and also some critical
responses and before those things were
invented you just couldn't do it it was
just it was
beyond the capacity but after they were
invented then you could be a science
fictional futurist mostly through
declaring to other people that you were
one and you and they had to hear you and
they had to agree they had to validate
your declaration it's like yeah you're
one of us here's your Hugo Award you
know whatever I am you could join the
science fiction writers of America but
without them you're just did the
Robinson Crusoe guy you know drawing
weird diagrams
[Music]
you